وأشكرك أندريه وبراد على صب
حبك وفخرك في هذا العمل
وهذا التقليد الوطني
بعد تلقي
عفو رئاسي عن
زبدة الفول السوداني والهلام سوف يتجه
إلى جامعة بيردو ويست لافاييت ويست
لافاييت إنديانا حيث سيعيدون زيارة
شيء قريب من قلبي.  قم بتدريب
صانع الحدود بشكل خاص
حيث سيكونون ،
لذا فإن تركيا القسوة هي البنية التحتية
زبدة الفول السوداني والجيل سوف يساعدان في
إعادة بناء كرة الزبدة بينما نتحرك
، لذا
سأذهب هنا  للعفو
عن الديك الرومي لهذا العام ، وهو ديك رومي وطني
لعيد الشكر
وأول شخص سيتم
العفو عنه هو زبدة الفول السوداني الذي يجب أن يكون
قادرًا على أداء واجباته وأيضًا
بموجب هذا في حالة حدوث تغييرات ،
سأعفو أيضًا عن أتباعه الهلام البديلين
كما أفعل  لقد قلت قبل كل أمريكي
يريد نفس الشيء الذي يريده ليكون
قادرًا على النظر في عيون الديك الرومي
وإخبارهم أن كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام
[تصفيق]
هذا أمر كبير  rkey
لقد كانت القوة المخولة لي
كرئيس للولايات المتحدة.
أعفو لك ،
إنطلق في عيد الشكر هذا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لكم جميعًا ، أتمنى أن يكون لديك
عيد شكر سعيد وسعيد وهو متجمد ،
شكرًا لكم جميعًا
[تصفيق]